dear evan hansen is a musical love
letter to all those who feel alone have
you been doing those letters to yourself
with dr sherman i've been trying to dear
evan hansen
today is going to be an amazing day
and here's why
because today all you have to do is just
be yourself
[Music]
but also confident that's that's
important and interesting easy to talk
to approachable but mostly just be
yourself you know that's number one
obviously be yourself but like a
confident version of yourself
i've learned to slam on the brake
before i even turn the key
before i make the mistake
before i lead with the worst of me
give them no reason to stare
no slipping up if you slip away
so i got nothing to share
no i got nothing to say
would you want to sign my cast because
we're friends we're family friends evan
would anyone even notice if i just
disappear tomorrow
sincerely our best and most dearest
friend me um no one signed your cast
now we can both pretend we have friends
uh dear evan hansen
yeah yeah that's mine i'll i'll just
take it wait i really i need that back
please don't show it to anyone on the
outside always looking in will i ever be
more than i've always been cause i'm tap
tap tapping on the glass
i'm waving through a window
i
try to speak upon
[Music]
connor took a letter from me and it was
an assignment from my therapist do
connor murphy's mother and stepfather
here to see you connor wanted you to
have this
dear evan hansen he wrote it to you his
last words conor took his own life hey
what
i'm sorry caller didn't write this no no
please we didn't think connor had any
friends
i mean you really going to tell these
people that the only thing they have
left of their son is a letter that you
wrote to yourself so you and connor tell
us something please heaven right um i
started talking to you you couldn't stop
they didn't want me to stop i'm putting
together a memorial service if you
wanted to do something you fall in the
forest and there's nobody around connor
showed me that that i wasn't alone
nobody is i wish we could have given
that
crash or thing make a sound
people started sharing it it's
everywhere i don't understand what
happened
you didn't make a sound it's like i
never made a sound will i ever make a
sound
[Music]
[Applause]
a lot of people feel like us people that
you wouldn't think you don't know how
much you've given my family and me
i never thought that it would go this
far i was trying to
[Music]
see help a health broken land
i already know you and i love you
i have to tell them
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you